[Applaudissements]
je ne vais pas vous mentir je ne peux
pas vous mentir
la musique a très mal débuté dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
non il faut pas se mentir tout a démarré
autour d'un feu d'un dîner dans une
grotte il ya quarante mille ans vous
avez trois hommes de cro magnon en train
de manger un vautour
tout ça est vrai il n'était pas très
regardant sur la bouffe à l'époque donc
ils sont en train de s'attaquer avec un
vautour mais il y en a un qui se fait de
manger un loto une patte de votto et ça
marche pas dont ils aspirent il souffre
il aspire est un seul coup il souffre un
peu trop fort et ça fait on arrête de
manger ses potes fait jean-pierre arrête
de jouer avec la nourriture enfin
tout ça est vrai les noms tout ça c'est
et je plaisante mais en fait c'est comme
ça que tout a commencé
le premier instrument le premier sont la
première note date d'il ya quarante
mille ans les premières fuites qu'on a
retrouvé tailler dans les os de vautour
date d'il ya quarante mille ans vous
imaginez c'est absolument incroyable
et alors la passion de souffler dans les
animaux à perdurer à travers le temps je
vous remercie parce que quand je les
écris ce cas là je me suis dit ça m'a
fait rire personne au fait merci
beaucoup et en fait par exemple est ce
que vous savez ce que c'est un chauffard
à un gars qui conduit mal un chauffard
ça se fait ce sont là est une corne de
bélier qui est utilisé dans la religion
juive par exemple pour indiquer la fin
du jeune de yom kippour
et en parlant de religion justement les
religions très vite essayé de
s'approprier la musique
peut-être pour la la citation qu'on peut
trouver dans la bible dieu ne se donne
pas à voir mais se donne à entendre
incroyable vous imaginez ce que cela
sous-entend la force du son et la force
de la voix c'est peut-être ce qui a
donné l'idée de lier au pape grégoire de
pousser la chansonnette et qui a inventé
les mélodies monodique on appelle ça les
chants grégoriens mais à l'époque il
appelait ça des mélodies monodique c'est
à dire une seule mélodie un seul son je
vais vous faire écouter une mélodie du
xiiie siècle un dia syrah et écoutez
bien ça devrait vous dire quelque chose
j'ai entendu quelqu'un dire on ne peut
pas rire sur ça vous avez la mélodie en
tête puis ben par un parent pas mais en
fait c'est le premier embellissement de
la musique peut-être puisque berlioz
deux siècles plus tard dans sa symphonie
fantastique à utiliser le même motif et
une petite cloche cadeaux
voilà
[Musique]
il était comme ça berlioz y comptait pas
y fait vivre est une cloche sonne et
mettez le moi ça me va ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est de se l'imaginer que
la musique et la technique a évolué en
même temps dire que après les chants
mode dit que vous avez la polyphonie
c'est à dire plusieurs notes d accord et
puis les instruments aussi le violon par
exemple est arrivé fascinant avec le
violon c'est encore 7,7 envie de faire
du mal aux animaux
je vous rappelle que le violon la
recherche et du crin de cheval et les
cordes c'était du boyaux de mouton
je crois que la musique est pavée
gagnent en fait une semble enfin c'est
le moment on peut se dire non c'est pas
possible
par chance les plus grands compositeurs
ont magnifié l'instrument avec des chefs
d'oeuvre intemporel qui se sont
transformés parfois en attente
téléphonique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne quittez pas les quatre saisons de
vivaldi vivaldi bach mozart buxeuil de
tous sans exception ont été cités mais
pas volé inciter des petits bouts de
mélodies de leurs prédécesseurs souvent
pour leur rendre hommage
pourquoi parce que y'a rien de plus
fascinant en musique que de s'appuyer
sur une mélodie qui est déjà dans
l'inconscient collectif
c'est quand même beaucoup plus facile à
mémoriser et puis c'est une façon de
dire aussi gars j'aime beaucoup ce que
tu fais oui marley pas comme ça à
l'époque mais c'est à peu près l'idée si
vous n'avez pas été étonnés d'entendre
chez berlioz des chants grégoriens vous
allez être certainement ravis de savoir
qu'il y a kylie a dû rachmaninoff
chéhéry carmen m'essayer ricard men
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous embrasser un an et demi
je vois pas d'autre manière
les briques à ces interdits par contre
parce que ça prend feu donc donc au
début de cette chanson all by myself
vous avez l'introduction écoutez bien la
mélodie de l'introduction nous y sommes
[Musique]
je peux pas m'empêcher de faire en
playback
j'adore
oui enfin on va l'écouter en entier ça
va durer merci de rire à mes bêtises
imaginez qu'à l'intérieur de cette
chanson il y à du rachmaninov pourquoi
parceque il écoutait rachmaninoff petit
eric carmen il écoutait quoi il écoutait
le concerto numéro 2 pour piano et donc
quoi de plus joli que de rendre hommage
à rachmaninoff en utilisant cette
mélodie rachmaninoff écoutez bien
la même chose rachmaninoff ne pouvait
pas imaginer un seul instant qu'on
allait danser sur sa chanson les stands
non mais c'est vrai et s'embrasser je
dis pas ça pour rire s'est imaginé c'est
d'un édile et christa et d'un seul coup
cette mélodie traverse les âges et
arrivent vers un auditoire qui n'était
pas du tout classique
[Musique]
c'est assez bon quand même
tel que vous voyez là regardez de
profils aussi j'ai rencontré sting
je lui suis pour rien il n'est pas là
soir mais j'ai rencontré sting qui était
un garçon exquis et je vous le confirme
il est très beau et charismatique jolie
en fait
sting on dit en parlant avec lui me
faisait part de sa passion pour les
compositeurs russes et en particulier
pour prokofiev
pourquoi fief qui a écrit roméo et
juliette et pierre et le loup le plus
connu il a décidé lui aussi de citer
prokofiev dans un de ses morceaux vous
souvenir la chose
[Musique]
85 certains d'entre vous n'étaient pas
nés
alors oui ça fait mal on vous dit 3,85
j'ai des souvenirs de 85 en fait dans ce
morceau il ya une mélodie incroyable il
ne vous a pas échappé
[Musique]
vous souvenez de cette mélodie si je la
distance de cinq demi ton jeu l'a
ralenti
[Musique]
et bien en fait cette mélodie c'est une
mélodie écrite par prokofiev qui
s'appelle lieutenant qui j'ai une suite
pour orchestre écoutez bien
[Musique]
et là aussi vous pouvez l'écouter ce
soir en rentrant c'est très très beau
puisqu'elle fait prokofiev d'ailleurs
il faut que j'arrête parce que j'ai
envie d'écouter jusqu'au bout mais après
on a d'autres eu qu'à faire je vous
propose maintenant de faire un bond dans
le temps
vous êtes vraiment un public star parce
que c'est pas ma meilleure mal
franchement merci p
[Musique]
je vais m'arrêter là j'ai peur de ne pas
faire mieux après oui ce que j'ai à dire
c'est mieux rester comme ça en hauteur
ce qui est intéressant on l'a vu avec le
violon et les boyaux de mouton c'est que
en fait la technique et la technologie
aident beaucoup la musique
là on fait un gros bond dont un bond
dans le temps et on va à l'heure du
numérique et de l'échantillonnage du
sampling le sampling
c'est un truc qui est arrivé début 80
qui permet de prendre un petit morceau
de une petite portion d'un titre et de
reconstruire un morceau en utilisant des
toutes petites portions je vous faire la
démonstration avec un titre de soixante
dix neuf des dix jones que vous n'avez
peut-être jamais entendu c'est le moment
danse
[Musique]
à vous dit rien comme ça - en bleu à
l'intérieur de ce morceau
il ya une partie instrumentale avec des
cuivres
[Musique]
non ils n'ont pas si je prends cette
partie instrumentale avec des cuivres et
que je coupe des tout petits bouts mais
des toutes petites portions
je prends ça par exemple où ça ou ça
hein ah ça commence à vous dire quelque
chose
ne bougez pas
daft punk ou one more time
[Applaudissements]
j'ai écrit ça en deux minutes comme ça
avant de venir comme ça sur un coup de
tête je rallie tac qui est intéressant
c'est que dans les années 80 90
s'il ya bien un genre musical qui a été
magnifié recyclé utilisé est célébrée
c'est le disco le funk et c'est vrai que
début 2000 les rappeurs ont été chercher
un peu plus loin et on fait ce qu'on
appelle dans le langage des dj du crecq
digging what is bringing vous avez vu
cet anglais impeccable c'est d'aller
chercher dans des vinyles un peu plus
loin que jean rabasse les dons santé on
va le prendre on va faire des boucles un
an elle y chercher un peu plus loin ça
veut dire aller faire des associations
improbables comme je vais vous le
montrer maintenant imaginez dr dre avec
un titre qui s'appelle watts des fleurs
[Musique]
l'intro de cette chanson c'est ça
imaginez que dr dre il était fan du
grand charles charles aznavour oui le
truc de dingue
charles aznavour et sur les 1000
chansons écrites par charles aznavour il
y a puisque tu crois parce que tu crois
pas que tu m as tu me laisses et là vous
me dit ok on l'a perdue il ya aucun
rapport serait comme vous je suis assis
là je fais ça y est c'est mon lâcher la
rampe
on le retrouvera plus si on prend
l'introduction de la chanson parce que
tu crois c'est quoi c'est mon la
ralentit un peu je rajoute un pied de
grosse caisse et voilà
dr dre as d'amour même combat c'est pas
un magnifique embellissement ça et dingo
et là c'est le moment où vous me dites
et et le jazz pendant ce temps là non
avec enthousiasme j'y crois pas ça fait
je me sens vous êtes forcé si vous
demandez comme ça je vais vous répondre
eh bien imaginez que le jazz est une
invention française oui une invention
française puisque en 1792 il y avait une
danse qui saperait le quadrille c'était
un peu une sorte de speed dating de
l'époque vous dansiez avec votre fiancée
je rigole pas un je respecte les bleus
vous mettiez un peu à peu j'ai dit non
il fallait faire mouche pin up et vous
change et ici ça faisait comme ça
évidemment quand je leur raconte vous me
croyez pas parce que j'ai une tête de
crue du je vous assure que c'est vrai
[Musique]
même certains 92 kadri des tuileries
pour être prescrits vous voyez comment
c'est fait faire un peu martial vous
avez une main gauche bon si je vous
isole la main gauche
ça fait ça oui savait s'amuser à
l'époque génial bougeait dans le truc
intéressant c'est que les planteurs de
louisiane qui était à paris vont en
louisiane et arrive et dans les maisons
coloniales il y avait évidemment des
pianistes de jazz et un pianiste de jazz
d'antan ça et décide de rajouter une
mélodie dessus ça vous avez toujours la
main gauche en tête pour mon bon il va
rajouter une mélodie et je vais vous
montrer comment en quelques mois
le cadre y est devenu le rac times
ragtime et bougez pas le truc est dingue
imaginez un la louisiane vous avez les
champs de coton vous avez encore les
esclaves qui sont là et qui chantent
imaginez qu'on rajoute une voie par
exemple dessus et le jazz est né le jazz
et le blues c'est pas incroyable tout ça
bon partant de 1592 des tuileries moi ça
me scie
et le blues le blues il a voulu
s'émanciper
le blues il a dit oui je veux sortir
plus tard
oui ça va je veux mettre un blouson noir
avec des pâquis pointu oui je peux me
rachid je veux oui et le blues est
devenu le rock c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé
et quand le rock est arrivé alors là là
le vivier le vivier d'assemblage du
nombrilisme ans est devenue colossale
prenez par exemple ce titre mythique
hôtel california c'est le deuxième
moment vous pouvez vous embrasser n'y en
aura pas d'autre profitez-en
si vous n'avez pas fait sur le premier
c'est le moment imaginez que cette suite
d'accords et la mélodie en fait il avait
entendu de façon inconsciente chez ge et
rotule jettent rotule c'est un groupe
qui avait donc dont d'ailleurs eagles
avaient fait la première partie pour la
petite histoire
écoutez bien c'est assez proche
[Musique]
sur le relief
vous pouvez écouter les deux c'est
génial mais on peut plus embrasser sur
la première que soit la deuxième c'est à
choisir plus on va loin et plus on se
rapproche de notre époque avec la pop et
plus en fait les emprunts les citations
les embellissements sont assez courts
est ce que vous vous souvenez de
gauthier en 2011 le gaver la voix de
sting après vous vous souvenez de
l'intro est en fait gauthier il était
fan d'un des pères de la bossa nova
qu'ils appellent luiz bonfa quel on
pense pas mais tu es un génie absolu et
écouter ce type de 67 et après ça
apporte autre chose mais ce que je
boucle la première partie peut faire ça
pendant une heure et demi mon ado truc à
faire donc vous avez vous êtes rendu
compte que en fait plus on avance dans
la musique et plus la pop la musique
populaire je vous rappelle que cela
diminue le diminutif utilise très peu
d'extraits musicaux et très peu
d'accords est là devant vos yeux ébahis
vos oreilles et bay aussi d'ailleurs
vous savez la différence entre les yeux
et les oreilles
je rigole pas les oreilles n'ont pas de
paupières
non on peut pas cligner des oreilles ou
est-ce que j'ai on peut pas ne pas vous
voulez pas voir un truc vous fait à mon
dieu il est viable et les oreilles on
peut pas je suis en train de perdre un
temps infini et je suis en train de vous
perdre si je me rends compte que je suis
désolé en fait ce qui est fascinant
c'est de se dire que une dizaine de
tubes des tubes mais des tubes cosmiques
ont été écrits sur uniquement quatre
accords quatre accords qui sont ceux ci
rés la cie sol
et pour m'aider dans cette lourde tâche
je vous demande et d'applaudir comme il
se doit la merveilleuse sont deux camps
disparue
bonsoir je ne mérite pas autant
totalement j'aimerais donc avec quatre
accords on va faire une dizaine de
chansons et on voit comment attend donc
si j'ai bien compris tu vas faire quatre
accords et je vais chanter dix chansons
ouais t'as pas l'impression que c'est
moi qui fait tout le boulot là non
[Musique]
hadopi
nous menons
non enfin
souffrions ses 20 ans le plus joli des
enfants damman prince charmant a conçu
son chemin
nous
chez les petites histoires
je ne
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bruay houdain et je marche seul dans les
rues 10 de tonnes
il annuler ma part je marche seul
vdans
voulant voir monsieur han
inquiet
vidéo
dieu
où
pourtant quelqu'un m'a dit
tu me manques en sa personne qui
m'attend
est ce possible
et
[Musique]
ah oui j
vous
[Musique]
en
news
[Musique]
m
en fait en fait ce talk s'appelait
recyclage et embellissement candice
parise beit-salam alex jaffray pour
terminer pour terminer car il est déjà
21h30 on s'en fout on rigole on rigole
et temps passe vite
en fait la personne qui illustrent mieux
l'embellissement musical c'est victor
hugo avec une citation qu'on adore tous
les deux qu'ils aient les monuments
appartiennent à leur propriétaire
leur beauté à tout le monde merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici